salve no un'altra ascensore perfetto
bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fan di j
oggi siamo su un videogame molto
particolare un indie chiama toseland
airspace praticamente dovrebbe essere
slann der nello spazio quindi laga non
so che cosa sto per andare a giocare ma
articolo mi ha incuriosito un casi non
tanto meno sembra figo è perché non
andare su single player o che siamo già
partiti
ok ok è un incrocio tra the space is
lander permettono già capito un cazzo
però madonna che cazzo sul suo zio
siamo partiti malissimo s'è spenta la
luce ok perfetto adesso ci vedo per modo
di dire eh va beh devo aprire le porte
non sommando ok come l'ho aperta non lo
so ma l'offerta si sembra
un'ambientazione molto simile a desideri
soltanto che si inceppa tra portano ok
facciamo che andare nel corridoio raga
vi dicevo non ho visto niente non ho
visto trailer non ho visto screenshot di
questo video che non ho visto nulla
completamente nulla è l'unico videogame
forse che ho giocato fino ad ora di cui
non ho visto proprio niente magari poi
mi fa cagare non lo carico neanche sto
video per dire però vabbè ci sono i
cessi intanto pulitissimi anche nello
spazio
va beh non c'è nulla qui ok devono
trovare dei power nodes che non so che
cosa sono non so neanche dove sono più
che altro ma
vabbè devo trovargli e andiamo che nel
bagno degli uomini abbiamo realizzato
che non c'è una mazza quindi andiamo in
quello delle donne è permesso scusate
devo trovare qualcosa tipo un power nord
che non so che cos'è ok
non c'è niente i bagni sono
completamente vuoti non è che devo
guardare nei cessi no perché diciamo non
vorrei trovare brutte sorprese diciamo
nei cessi quindi meglio che esca
vabbè soprattutto se non salendo era già
fatto cagare in mano qualcuno tra
l'altro sono anche curioso di vedere
come lo slider nello spazio ok che bella
stanza candeo mio dio che ci faccio bene
raga dove siamo è permesso avete una
porta semiaperta io ci entrò anche per
questa stanza non promette bene ok c'è
qualcosa che lampeggia qui devo andare
dall'altra parte raga c'è qualcosa che
lampeggia forse un power nozzo anche se
non so che cosa è semplicemente sta roba
che non so che cos'è sinceramente quindi
niente
va beh non c'è niente neanche qui quindi
non so che cosa ci siamo detti ok ok
oddio oddio madonna si muove tipo jackie
chan lo slang bene ok fatto io mi
rifugio qui dentro perfetto se n'è
andato
che cos'è sta roba ok raga forse l'ho
trovato un power non credo se uno su sei
ok ragano trovato bene
siamo uno su sei spero che se ne sia
andato
forse ne è andato non se n'è andato per
niente ok ok calmi
allora qua mi serve la mano zio ma
questo si muove anche se non lo zio
ok ok questo si muove anche se stai
girato dalla sua parte e questo mi
preoccupa perché mi potrebbe spuntare da
un momento all'altro anche adesso
ok è caduto il burrocacao mi son cagato
addosso [ __ ] ok ci sia
raga dio mio tantissimo ma chi ti ha
scordato il torace oddio mamma mia
jackie chan ti fa una bocca
il grazie bene abbiamo perso come si fa
a ripartire exit game
ok ragazzi amori partiti benissimo
allora come primo tentativo è andato
abbastanza di merda che cazzo suo addio
perfetto incidenti allora non si guidano
le navicelle ubriachi
ok adesso ho capito effettivamente
perché è saltata la corrente bene ok non
l'avevo visto all'inizio perfetto allora
veramente epico come inizio comunque per
essere un indie a parte la grafica ma
vabè la grafica degli di chi se ne frega
è veramente fatto bene cioè non meno
spessi chiaramente liz lander che
c'erano piante sono completamente
diversi da questo molto meglio però come
idea c'è lander nello spazio ancora non
avevano fatto mi piace anche l'idea che
si muova tipo una roba
com fus lander e soprattutto per il
fatto che si muove anche se non lo
guardi e come cosa è veramente
raccapricciante allora ok ragazze lowes
rendersi fotta io lì non c entro più
devo andare o nel corridoio bello
allegro o nell'altra porta allora io
consiglierei corridoio bello allegro
all'inizio anche se comunque in quella
stanza prima invece no ho sentito rumore
ok dove dove dove dove dove dove dove
piano non lo vedo
ho visto soltanto l'interferenza raga ok
raga non lo vedo ma tentò di passare la
sua muro per questo punto se non mi
prende con l'interferenza anche se non
lo vedo siamo in una cabina ma che cazzo
ok beh fantastico pago rafa childcare
center
penso si pronunci così altrimenti ho
fatto una figura di merda ma chi se ne
frega
c'è un balcone le barre mancano tutti
gli alcolici ma va beh lo slang anzi si
era già dato alla pazza gioia cede ci
sono delle porte fantastiche c'è un
ascensore devo buttare mica giu
no vero no perfetta non ci sono comunque
delle dei power not in giro quindi devo
tornare indietro e non promette bene il
fatto che devo tornare indietro perché
fuori
minecraft si sarà tutta pubblicità oddio
oddio guardate il bastardo buongiorno si
accomodi
il viaggio sarà molto molto intenso io
se non le dispiace
faccio il giro e vado di la rai che
attraverso le panchine non c'è
l'interferenza brutta stanza non mi
prendi brutto stronzo mi chiamo mi salta
addosso mi prendo un infarto di quelli
assunti faccia delle mani che riescono
dal dio mio ma che schifo non si può
correre in questo slider po più veloce
lui di meno altro po
io me ne vado me ne vado vado vado
avanti che promette bene tu style è ok
ci sono dei ma che bello
bene finchè non esce sono contento
allora deve entra in una delle porte
anche alla svelta dentro in questa
apriti ok oddio oddio ma che cazzo è c'è
ma scherziamo
oddio bene ma si sono sedute un po di
donne con le mestruazioni oppure lo
slider ci ha dato di suo cioè non lo so
però sinceramente non voglio saperlo
andiamo avanti sta portati apre no
perfetto non so dove andare lì no lì ci
sono entrato prima ok allora devo andare
avanti ancora c'era un'altra porta
all'indietro che non ancora aperto
normalmente ci sono miliardo di porta
che non ha ancora aperto ma non voglio
aprire allora non so dove andare
perfetto sono tutti uguali sti posti del
cazzo non andiamo a destra
ok raga torniamo indietro io direi che è
lì in fondo non so che cosa c'è di altro
di sicuro dimenticato dei nodi di sicuro
però io non ci torno più vasta basta
andiamo di qua che sta porta ancora non
l'ho aperto nome
si aprono perfetto allora nel cesso
c'ero già stato però probabilmente un
altro perché non ce ne saranno tanti
penso
vabbè c'è qualcosa che luccica vista ok
come hanno detto allora di nodi a
perfetto c'è un nodo energetico nel
cesso ok
la cosa che non mi sarei mai aspettato
bene siamo a 1
siamo ora un [ __ ] nodo energetico
ieri praticamente uno su sei ne avrò
dimenticati ma di sicuro tre o quattro
però vabbè c'è qualcosa dai madonna
santissima sono vivo io sono solo io
sono io sono vivo sono vivo io ma che
cazzo ma chi cazzo che se lo fa
porca [ __ ] madonna che ha stordito un
orecchio anzi due
oddio bene questo che cazzo perfetto ok
ragazzi haven trappola t nel cesso a
questo punto tira lo sciacquone merda è
un problema questo allora raga devo
riuscire a tentare di aggirarlo passando
vicino al muro per ho paura che non ce
la faccio però la boe come al solito
proviamoci
con tutto il rispetto se ne vada a fare
in culo che mi ha stordito non è ok
chi cazzo abbiamo perso sono solo un
[ __ ] genio veramente raga a volte mi
stupisco di me stesso non so come faccia
essere così idiota non lo so non me lo
chiedete non lo so fino ad ora raga
siamo andati da quella parte all'inizio
questa volta provo ad andare dalla parte
opposta anche se sinceramente non idea
di che cosa ci possa essere
come al solito corridoi molto diversi a
una prima occhiata sembra identica la
parte opposta
se qua ci sono i cessi è praticamente
uguale allora identica perfetto devono
soltanto riuscire a trovare ok ok
perfetto allora praticamente ok ok non
ci passa è troppo alto no ci passa ci
passa aiuto aiuto
ok
no o cazz o cazzo mi sa che sfonda ok
bene gira e rigira finiamo sempre nel
cesso perfetto
raga forse è meglio che me la dia gambe
prima che sfondi la porta ok ok ok
siamo di nuovo in trap no vabbè dai
ragazzi ma perché mi intrappolano nel
cesso ma ma in un qualsiasi altro posto
non va bene
c'è allora a meno che non riesca a
tirare lo sciacquone non posso salvarmi
mi scusi devo riuscire sparito è sparito
esperita non ci credo non è sparito un
cazzo ok ma forse ci dai dai vedere
vedere lei apriti maledetto stronza
certo se ce la fa
non so come cazzo ho fatto ma ce l'ho
fatta sesto bradipo sid ha magari una
mossa posso anche correre no non posso
correre bene devo riuscire a trovare
quei fottuti nodi mi sta già
raggiungendo merda allora di quale non
c'era ancora andato bassi sembrano non
ho la più pallida idea di che cosa sono
sti cosi non lo voglio sapere
dobbiamo muoverci per perfetto raga vedo
una porta vedo una porta semi aperta tra
l'altro
salve no un altro ascensore perfetto
porca [ __ ] è caduto qualcosa è accaduto
qualcosa mi scusi c'è qualcun altro la
sua bene bene bene bene bene muoviamo il
culo muoviamo il culo muoviamo il culo
muoviamo il culo
raga non ci sono non posso uscire non
posso ok ok situazione di merda non
posso uscire nel cielo slam
ok perfetto perfetto perfetto buttati
giù suicidati suicidate ok ok suicidati
maledetto stronzo buttati giu ok ok ok
ok laga prova da girarlo senza guardare
provo ad aggirarlo senza guardare prova
raggirarlo senza guardare se stessa
facendo i ragazzi
ringrazio di aver trovato uno slider
idiota perché veramente sarei dovuto
morire nel cesso già da prima però
fortunatamente lo sa rendere un idiota e
più idiota di me ce ne vuole per essere
piloti di meo che cosa c'è qua non c'è
nessuno in sti cosi che sinceramente non
ho capito neanche che cosa sono
ma non voglio saperlo sinceramente io mi
spiego come non svende faccia passare di
qua perché a malapena ci passo io
comunque va beh
proseguiamo c'è qualcosa di qua la mensa
la messa dammi un piatto di scopa raga
siamo in me c'è un nodo energetico
perfetto ok non so se immensa la voglio
trovare ma ci provo lo stesso quindi
dov'è la nutella
devo dirlo devo dirlo quando entro in
dove c'è da mangiare devo vedere se c'è
la nutella perché sennò non son contento
ok c'è una porta chiusa che penso sia
quella di prima che si aprirà coi nomadi
quasi sicuramente per oggi nodo devo 1 o
un [ __ ] noto su sei sono un mito che
cazzo c'è scritto oh dio
un nodo un nodo che i tre su sei ok 444
qua ok pian piano ce la stiamo facendo
quattro su sei laws lander non si è
fatto più vedere saranno una decina di
minuti buoni ho fatto anche dei tagli
perché non è successo niente è una
decina di minuti buoni che sto giocando
e non è apparso più secondo me si è
incastrato dove siano le barelle però
non lo so non ne sono sicuro
tentero di andare a vedere adesso se
effettivamente ancora al incastrato non
lo fate voi voi non lo fate lo faccio io
perché sono un pazzoide ok perfetto se
sta porta si apre mi fa un piacere
ok grazie vado a vedere un attimo se
e rimasto incastrato poverini in mezzo
alle barelle perché di giorno davvero
non è più scontato neanche una volta mi
sembra strano avevo dimenticato dei no
di qua non lo so neanche aspettare un
attimo che prova ad uscire lo slider
davvero non si è fatto più vedere mi
sembra stranissimo c'è no non mi
sembrava di vedere qualcosa di luminoso
laggiù no non c'è niente ragazzi
sostanza non c'è nulla non ci sono i
nodi luminosi novi sad e bloccato il
tasto mi si è bloccato il tasto vi si è
bloccato il tasto non ci posso credere
madonna mia sun tosto tasto di merda di
giu
ma si può morire così mi è rimasto
bloccato il tasto per andare avanti
maledizione devo cambiare tastiera laga
tra poco cambierò tastiera ve lo dico
perché questa non la sopporto più allora
raga per questo episodio lo svenderà la
mia tastiera hanno vinto
non penso che farò ancora una volta
lander space ve lo lascio comunque in
descrizione come i videogiochi come
tutti i video giochi indie che faccio se
siete così pazzi da provare lo
scaricatelo e fatemi sapere se riuscita
a vincere anche se comunque come i
lander non è tanto difficile se lo
incastrate nelle barelle non è tanto
difficile
la cosa difficile trovare i nodi in giro
che io non li trovo so che sono impedito
io ma non li trovo eh va beh direi che
per questo episodio posso chiudere qui
servi dove è piaciuto una solito
lasciato un momento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook come in ogni video
trovate nella descrizione se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi